our patreon recommended that i diagnose
spongebob episodes let's just do
nickelodeon and get a bunch in there see
if your favorite show's reviewed
i'll cater to your every whim until that
leg of yours is entirely healed i don't
know what injury she has but that's a
full leg cast above the knee i don't
know what injury she had
that's not a bad idea
[Music]
what happened munchausen syndrome in
full effect when a patient pretends to
be ill in order to gain attention and or
sympathy there's actually a munchausen
by proxy where someone can actively make
like their child ill to get attention
and sympathy for the both of them it's a
really devastating illness because it
presents so many complications like the
doctor has to even suspect that it's
potentially happening what are you gonna
do i'm gonna take pictures of your
insides say cheese
we don't get full body x-rays for a leg
pain
there's no point of that it's just
exposing you to more radiation they're
targeted it's kind of strange at first
but after a while you get to like it
when the x-ray tech or the radiology
specialist is in there with you they
actually start the machine up go behind
a wall so they're protected because
otherwise they're exposed to so much
radiation over the dozens and dozens
tests they do in a given day it's not
healthy
we'll be sick forever unless i can
extract some mitochondria from the virus
and make a vaccine okay medically he
just spoke gibberish getting the
mitochondria
the energy center of the cell not the
powerhouse of the cell will not allow
you to create a vaccine if you want to
create a vaccine you create a protein on
the surface of it then you put it into
the body and allow the immune system to
recognize it you know the way that we
traditionally make vaccines i don't know
what he's talking about
[Music]
look there's coral's brain
where i don't see it
is it behind that one on a stick your
brain is a lot bigger than that i got
people inside me why whenever they do
medical procedures on cartoons they like
scrap people in like it's a torture
device
all right they just traveled into the
stomach so right away if this was to
happen the acid would melt their little
inflatable raft here and they would fall
into the acid and lose their lives which
is why by the way drinking alconized
water is complete horse poop the reason
i say it is because when you drink the
alkalinized water that means it has like
a ph of eight instead of seven it falls
into your stomach acid which has a ph of
like two what do you think happens to
the ph of eight when it mixes with a
huge container ph of two
no longer alkaline
well where do next
the mountain the arctic i feel like
these are the current devices we have
now you hop on a peloton and it's like
where do you want to ride through what
trail and to me like i understand a lot
of people don't have time to go outside
or the weather's not cooperative but
like folks spend some time outdoors it's
cool too
oh no you need to start out slow doug
see
the important thing is not destrain
yourself
[Music]
amazing advice no joke in a cartoon
right now i had to just get back into
working out i used to bench like 255 285
during my workouts the other day i was
doing 95 and it's okay it bruises the
ego but it strengthens the muscles
nothing like a sea nut butter and
jellyfish jelly sandwich ew see nut
butter oh that sounds gross to help you
get to sleep
and ideally you don't eat too close to
bedtime because then your stomach
produces all those gastric juices highly
acidic and then when you lie down and
you're parallel to the floor and the
gastric juices starts coming up you get
heartburn
fridge syndrome
the fridge no lie that's how i sleep i
love it freezing i like to sleep with
multiple covers with a hoodie on
sometimes i actually just got like one
of these cooling mattresses maybe it's
because i grew up in siberia and when i
was in my mom's womb i was like freezing
all the time so i want to go back to
that that's why we sleep in the fetal
position
don't be silly gary i don't get cold
i get the studs
no
no gary
if i had the suds i'd have bubbles
coming out of me
[Music]
oh no he has the suds grandma was right
to a degree if you go outside and your
hair is wet or you get a chill it
doesn't mean that you're gonna get sick
it can just make you a little bit more
susceptible than you were before
hey spongebob i'm sick patrick i'm gonna
go ahead and guess that he has a dental
virus because you know he has the
conjuctiva that's inflamed he has the
upper respiratory symptoms i don't know
if he has diarrhea i mean he probably
doesn't have diarrhea because he's a
cartoon sponge after all but if a
cartoon sponge was to have diarrhea and
inflamed conjuctiva and upper
respiratory symptoms adenovirus i know a
guy who knows a guy who went to the
doctor once and the doctor's office is a
horrible horrible place it is not we
have fun there
well first they make you sit in the
waiting room is that the horrible part
patrick no it gets worse
they make you read old magazines i don't
know why that is can we update our
magazine collection in the medical
offices for god's sake who wants to read
about people magazine from 2006. i mean
we know britney was killing it back then
but we want to know what's up now is
that the year she was killing then the
doctor pulls out his stethoscope it's a
device so sinister
so icy cold when it touches your bear
flesh it
honestly the cold stethoscope is one of
the meanest things a provider can do for
you every time before i make contact
with the patient's chest and or back to
listen to lungs i do one of these
and i get some of the warmth of my hand
onto the stethoscope it's the least you
can do for your patients you gotta help
me get better patrick
please i'm so excited to see what
patrick's about to recommend if he says
manuka honey i might give the starfish a
high five
[Music]
i have been a doctor
for like seven eight years medical
school four years i do not know what
that thing is on patrick's head that
doctors used to wear back in the day it
doesn't make sense it reflects light i
it has a hole in the middle i have no
idea what it is what it does i've even
worn it as part of a halloween costume
oh my god i actually look like a doctor
it appears as though we'll have to plug
up these holes
this saw to do the trick
[Music]
feel better
i don't know well i'm going to do a
hyper analysis here see what's happening
is instead of treating spongebob's core
illness he's treating the symptoms only
this is a viral illness that's a
perfectly acceptable way to go about it
to allow the immune system time to heal
to rest to improve itself but if it's a
bacterial infection we're missing it
with treating symptoms and not treating
the underlying cause
it could be a big cause for concern
there patrick my lawyers will be in
touch or as my legal eagle friend says
it i'll see you in court i'll see you in
court
[Music]
feeling better yet
not really why'd he pull out his team
a boat
no
actually you may think this is silly
this is something we sort of do in the
hospitals it's called chest physical
therapy if a patient has a lot of mucus
we actually have specialized beds that
perform this like thumping feature that
helps clear out the mucus in patients
who have cystic fibrosis we actually
need this type of chest physical therapy
to be done on a regular basis in order
to help them expel that mucus and
prevent blockages in the airways kind of
crazy that spongebob has some level of
medical accuracy who knew it seems you
have the suds are you ready for your
treatment
the doctor's wearing the thing again
what is that thing what is it
and why is there a fish anatomy in the
background when there's a sponge patient
different species
well it looks like your gluteus maximus
has made a full recovery oh his gluteus
maximus are using proper anatomical
terms i guess he tore a muscle in his
buttock your butt's all better it's
really quite amazing i love that they do
an x-ray first of all you can't x-ray
gluteus maximus you can't x-ray muscles
you can x-ray bones joints but not
muscles it took 20 hours to put it all
back together
we actually ran out of staples and had
to use a glue stick there is a fact here
in closing skin there are both of those
options for example if you get a cut on
your skull you could actually close it
with staples it works quite well if you
get a small cut on your hand we have
skin glue that can keep it together it's
not cool spongebob what's up
ah doctor thank goodness you're here
they're wearing the thing on their heads
again and what seems to be the problem
today
my throat hurts why is this patient
admitted inpatient into a hospital for a
throat ink with again a chart on the
bedside that looks like a stock market
chart more than a dozen ekg what even is
that i'll need one medical c chicken
[Music]
what's a medical situation
hey my keys
and my throat feels better
he's not a doctor
of humans
he's a vet
because they're in a fish tank
or at the bottom of the ocean
and there's a catfish
that ate some keys
and didn't have strep throat
but had
key throat
you saw that one subscribe
[Music]
little laryngitis oh those tonsils are
really enlarged general tonsillitis i
think we should take them out now we're
trying to move away from doing
tonsillectomies we're weighing the risks
versus benefits here and we're we have
like a set of guidelines that we follow
if you have x number of strep throats or
tonsillitis or pharyngitis that we get
you set up with an ent who then makes a
decision whether or not they need to
come out now we're trying to do our best
to manage it medically and not have to
resort to a surgical operation if we
don't need to that doesn't mean you
won't get surgery i'm just saying
there's options on the table
wow what am i gonna do arnold maybe if
you gargle or something garlic is
actually not a bad option uh also honey
you know i love my honey
are you having problems with your you
know what
no my the giggly gland is fine it is
what gland no it's not
cosmo's fa giggly gland is for giggly
gland i wonder what the giggly gland is
the special magical organ in a fairy's
body that allows us to
change shape
what is cosmo sex let me put this to you
in terms cosmo could understand
yes
why does the doctor keep putting the
glasses on taking them off and why is
the stethoscope floating i need extra
and he's wearing that thing what is that
thing
[Music]
oh no walking dead again
why are they all jaundiced
[Music]
it looks okay
986 degrees 98.6 degrees normal body
temperature this morning our house
became infested with an acute febrile
contagious virus or as it's known on the
street
the flu oh the flu we haven't seen much
of that lately with 13 loads packed into
1200 square feet when someone gets sick
it spreads like the plague that's true
actually in like college dorm rooms
military barracks anytime you have
people living in close proximity it's
very easy for one person get sick and
then get everybody else sick in case
you're attacked this concoction will
slow down the
infected what is it boogers tastes like
chicken soup oh that's because it is
chicken soup i would be just shooting
that in my mouth all day i love chicken
soup
[Music]
they won't let go
[Music]
stop making so much noise it's just a
purple pentapus oh it's a purple
pentapus it's never heard of a purple
pentapus i don't know why this popped
into my head if you ever heard of
molluscum contain geosum it sounds
really serious but it's not really that
scary of a virus that causes like these
little skin pearly papules to pop up it
happens more often in kids people who
share towels sometimes they're sexually
transferred
i like when they just like rub them like
that
and they just pop right off
[Music]
morgan school
good morning class good morning miss
pancreas miss pancrease
yes bladder that doesn't look like a
bladder that looks like a lemon can i go
to the bathroom and ironic that the
bladder ass to go you'll have to wait
till after roll call oh my god this is
so embarrassing i remember in like
second or third grade i asked teacher to
go to the bathroom and she said no and i
peed myself in class
someone said like oh what's that liquid
next to your desk i'm like i spilled a
water bottle
thank god my pants dried quickly so
embarrassing i can't believe i'm talking
about it
kids sometimes ask me weird medical
questions click here to check that out
and as always stay happy and
[Music]